all right joining me now is Ari
Fleischer former White House Press
Secretary Fox News contributor and
Victor Davis Hanson senior fellow at the
Hoover institution all right Ari um
Biden tonight
is that a winning message given what the
country American families are facing
well first it's a losing message in the
fact that he could have tried at least
to do some of these things when the
Democrats controlled the house and the
Senate but the Democrats no longer
controlled the house and you know Joe
Biden making all these promises to do
these things that are going to go
nowhere so it's all about the Democrat
base
when he goes to a retreat like this
Laura it's all about rallying the
Democratic base making sure that the
liberal Community the progressive
Community thinks he's there he's one of
them and that's been the fundamental
flaw of the Biden Administration they
govern and they speak like progressives
instead of moderates or centrists the
type of person Joe Biden the unifier
promised to be he's the last thing least
thing bar thing from being a unifier
talked about in the angle which is this
rank
corruption and political bias within one
of the most powerful agencies in the
United States and obviously there are
wonderful people who work in the FBI we
say that and that's obvious good men and
women who are committed
but we see example after example whether
it's Trump targeted parents targeted
traditional Catholics targeted uh poor
guy was just you know protesting outside
of an abortion clinic targeted and
Merrick Garland's like well yeah you
know those decisions are made on the
ground or oh yeah that wasn't good but
there's no accountability zero what does
that say to America
well I think Americans are wondering
Laura is there anything the FBI won't do
Kevin kleinsmith the FBI lawyer is now a
felon he doctored a document they
offered Christopher Steele who had a
fake dossier he was offered a million
dollars by the FBI to find one true
thing he couldn't yet they use that fake
dossier to full of feisty judge a spy in
an American citizen they contracted
Twitter out and paid him three million
dollars to suppress information about a
laptop that affected the election this
white clean subpoena phones during the
Mueller investigation we have no need to
get into Lisa Page and Peter stroke
and the last four look at the last four
directors we had Robert Mueller who
swore under oath he didn't know what the
steel dossier was and he didn't know
what Fusion GPS was that was the pillars
of his entire investigation then we had
James Comey who played Amnesia 245 times
under oath we had Andrew McCabe who
admittedly lied to Federal investigators
four times these were the top people now
I don't need to get into Christopher Ray
he's very disingenuous so I don't think
people have they want to believe in the
FBI but they've lost all confidence in
the Washington leadership and neither
they should disperse it and put the
headquarters in Kansas or break up the
FBI and farm it out to different
agencies but it can't continue because
people are afraid of it
well I think what we're seeing as well
Ari is this attempt to blame shift on
issues like crime that when we can see
it before our very eyes I mean things
get more vicious more depraved I don't
think it's just anecdotal things are
changing in this country not for the
better when it comes to the crime issue
so kjp was asked about this today at
your old haunt The Briefing room this is
what she said
National Republicans have been doing the
opposite when you think about the cops
program which is something that the
president put forward they have wanted
to defund that to take that away and if
you think about that that leads to
defunding the police just recently they
called into funding the FBI and you
think about the border security funding
they want to take that away as well
now blaming the Republicans for the
seven million people I think it is that
have come across our border in two years
do we really need to look any further
than what happened in Chicago last night
in Chicago the mayor of Chicago Lori
Lightfoot who presides over a city where
she is vilified and demonize the police
department where crime is out of control
where liberal prosecutors have sent the
signals that you can get away with all
kinds of things that used to be felonies
that now have been made into
misdemeanors she lost her race for
re-election she came in a dismal place
she only got 16 percent of the vote she
doesn't even make the runoff this is the
reality of cities in America today where
people are voting on the things that
matter the most of them which is can you
safely walk to a neighborhood can you
safely send your children to a school at
the school will they be safe crime is a
tangible visible issue that affects
every American and the reason the
principal reason is democratic weakness
particularly with the DA's and the
prosecutors who've abandoned the pursuit
of justice for social for social causes
that are failing everybody
well Victor as well as change we may
still have the same party it looks like
representing the city of of Chicago so
again you got Eric Adams in New York
Miranda Devine pointed this out last
night so you know he came in he was
going to be the conservative Democrat or
the moderate Democrat and look at what's
happened I mean they need a change in
party do they not
yeah it's very sad because we're
destroying these great institutions that
have been with us for 230 years in some
cases and now it's just a question I
nobody nobody on the left believes it
works if you look at homelessness and
crime and the budget and the murder rate
Etc and it's the quality of life the
schools are all shot it's just a
question of the people who are living
there and most of them are tend to be
Progressive how long they want to commit
suicide and they know that the medicine
for them is worse than the disease the
medicine is rejecting the entire
Progressive agenda that brought
themselves such misery but to do so I
think they they don't they're not
capable of it yet but they're getting to
the peak point of where life won't be
sustainable and we're in such
civilizational decline I think they're
going to have to as we saw in Chicago
they're going to have to shock
themselves and look in the mirror and
said we did this to ourselves yeah it's
making an admission a failure that it's
over and it's hard to do that uh
gentlemen great to see both of you
thanks so much hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else